noch mal darum ins ziel zu kommen meine
lieben freunde ich habe vor zwei wochen
bereits ein video zu snapshot schluss
hochgeladen das ist das neue
bezahlmodell von snap chat bei dem man
dann komische
neuigkeiten und funktionen
freigeschaltet kriegt siehst du wirklich
wo diese person vorher war auf jeden
fall habe ich mein video by step + das
ganze ziemlich harsch kritisiert weil
seine krasse stalking kontroll richtung
geht und es nicht so ein bisschen black
mirror erinnert hat eine serie auf
netflix der ist unsere historische
zukunftsvorstellungen geht dass man in
die chips eingepflanzt bekommen und die
eltern dann genau sehen was die kinder
sehen ob man bestimmte sachen aus planen
kann und ich persönlich bin wirklich
jemand der sagt hey wir haben jetzt
smartphones ich kann hier auf den knopf
drücken anrufen und die man auf der
anderen seite der welt in australien
gehen innerhalb von fünf sekunden daran
und wir können telefoniert wir können
uns sehr bei facetime wir können im
flugzeug zueinander hinfliegen wiwo.de
ihr von mir ist brauchen wir keine hab
kein fortschritt mehr was das angeht
doch dann habe ich vor 2 stunden diesen
beitrag hier entdeckt von studio 71
germany the future ist virtual world im
juni jona ist eine faszinierende
persönlichkeit dabei spielt auch die
abbildung der diversität eine zentrale
rolle für studio 71 bei der anlage
dieser virtuellen
influenza in
eine virtuelle
influenza in virtueller influenza sind
künstlich geschaffene avatare mit
eigenen social media profilen
ursprünglich aus der gamer und science
fiction szene bekannte erweitern sich
ihre einsatzgebiete nun auf die sozialen
netzwerke vorreiter waren hier asien und
die usa zusätzlich zu dem virtuellen
aussehen wird den influenza ebenfalls
eine virtuelle persönlichkeit sowie
stimme verliehen
mir geht es wirklich nicht darum dass
sich die konkurrenz für meinen job sehr
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich finde es ein
paar berufe medien schauspieler sportler
musiker influenza youtube können niemals
ersetzt werden durch roboter oder
virtuell computergenerierte
persönlichkeiten aber
ich habe wirklich schutz vor der zukunft
ins studio 71 hat an diesen linkedin
beitrag den die gepostet haben noch
dieses bild -angaben
bruder man sieht jeder einzelne pore das
ist kein echter mensch das ist computer
für diese yu na dann allerdings erst mal
genauer angeschaut habe habe ich erst
mal die kommentare geguckt weil ich
dachte mensch das kann doch nicht gut
finden mega kongress an das ganze team
das ist wirklich innovativ interessant
zu beobachten und vor allem fast vor der
zeit ich bin gespannt großartig was man
mit so einem thema auf die beine stellen
kann dank an alle die dabei sind ich
meine wirklich also auch noch frau laut
studie ein 70 das ist ja krass gemacht
ich meine hier nochmal das bild
das ist crazy und einfach die idee zu
kommen
die idee ist nicht ganz neu die gab es
schon länger dass sie jetzt zum beispiel
der instagram account von einer spanisch
sprechenden virtuellen in finsteren
namens magazine luisa hat einfach 5,9
millionen follower macht aber trotzdem
nur so 600 likes probe hält also das
ganze thema virtuelle influenza gibt
schon seit ein paar jahren im
deutschsprachigen raum jedoch noch nicht
so richtig es gibt noch duo lingo gehen
die vielleicht dass so eine sprachen
lernen ist ja okay wenn ihr logo habt
das in den adler dann vielleicht
animiert und er macht irgendwas oder
wenn das rollo gabel dass der krieg die
gabel zwei augen oder wie bei
kinderschokolade dann hast du da kinder
schokolade und das glas milch und die
beiden paaren sich und sind dann schön
und tolle miteinander und einer
beziehung aber bei menschen wenn ich das
ganze auf das geht zu weit in so eine
richtung und
wir allerdings zurück zu studio 71 und
dem beitrag den die hochladen auf
linkedin vor ein paar stunden wo es halt
um diese virtuelle instanzen ging yu na
ich bin mal auf ihren instagram account
gekannt hat jetzt noch nicht so die
riesige reichweite aber sie hat auch
erst fünf bilder hochgeladen oder so
würde ich allerdings sagen dass wir uns
in kauf dass man ein bisschen genauer
anschauen das hier ist ihre bio sie
heißt julie ist digital creator hat als
spruch drin in youtube das katzenhaus
welcome to the universe the virtual life
in berlin und was tab exploring oder du
bist eine animation du kannst nicht
schauen wir uns jetzt allerdings mal
ihren ersten instagram post an das ist
nämlich 111 ii von ihr an einer
s-bahn-station aber
du bist animiert ein roboter du kannst
keine erfahrungen sammeln du kannst
keine emotionen erleben du kannst auch
keine neuen menschen kennenlernen ich
frag mich halt real talk was der
mehrwert für irgendwie ist diese person
war allerdings weiter mit dem nächsten
post in der sich vor zwei tagen
hochgeladen und charline caption ich bin
kaum hier und berlin habe ich direkt in
ihren bann gezogen deshalb hier ein paar
impressionen und ganz weit vorne mit
dabei der kaffee von bonanza mein neuer
verscheiden ich war das der erste
werbedeal
der dann allerdings auch nicht korrekt
gekennzeichnet wurde ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie man da dann anzeigen soll weil
sie bot aber gut dass hier sind auf
jeden fall die bilder die sie
hochgeladen hat also ein klassischer
denn sie ist jener tolles man filter
drauf und platz hoch post ist jetzt sind
nichts besonderes dritter paus von
universe reality was ihr seht und was
ich sehe ich lasse mir meinen instagram
moment trotz umzugs chaos nicht nehmen
du bist ein roboter brauchst keine möbel
du brauchst keinen kühlschrank keine
küche nicht zum hinsetzen und auch nicht
zum schlafen warum postet ihr dann ein
bild von ihnen welchen kartons
die wollen hier einfach zeigen das ist
ein echter mensch ist es aber nicht doch
dann kam der vierte post
und das waren realtech
moment tue
[Musik]
du kannst nun allerdings auch schon zu
ihrem bisher aktuellsten instagram post
also dem letzten denen sie bisher
hochgeladen hat dass dieser hier
das ist sie in ihrer wohnung mit einem
bild was sie da von sich irgendwie einem
spiel gemacht hat wo ich mich einfach
frage wo ist der spiegel steht er quer
zum raum in deinem bett drin oder was
schaut euch hier das bild noch mal
genauer an das ergibt absolut gar keinen
sinn wo sie dieses foto gemacht hat dass
ein computer freund von dir gemacht wenn
sich der donnerstag wie montag anfühlt
du hast keine gefühle
und in den kommentaren schildern auch
sowas einfach wie slayer oder great job
oder irgendwelche images das feiern oder
einer fragt danach kollaborations
fragezeichen aber den ganzen kreis ist
hier wirklich mal außen vor das ist die
absolut gar kein studio 1 70 oder das
entwicklerteam das gemacht haben denn
die haben einen super job gemacht sie
haben diesen charakter erstellt haben
dem leben eingehaucht und haben das
animiert und alles total spooky echt
hingekriegt und wenn es diesen trend ja
auch schon seit jahren in amerika oder
in asien gibt und da teilweise leute
irgendwie über fünf millionen follower
dann ist es einfach nur normal dass
deutschland irgendwann diese anderen
länder am kopieren es aber
das wird niemals funktionieren
ich verstehe das nicht also entwickelt
euch ruhig in so eine richtung versucht
euch daran aus ist es ja uncool und
crazy zu sehen aber es ist auf der einen
seite extrem motiviert und gruselig auf
der anderen seite wird man damit aber
auch nie erfolg haben ich sag's euch
diese einem universe account wird
niemals mehr als 500.000 follower
bekommen nicht mal 100.000 werden die
erreichen so weit den ich mich aus dem
fenster die folgen noch nicht dieser
person weil sie sich denken oh ja mich
interessiert voll was man anzieht weil
man ja nie sehen wird
roduner empfiehlt das café ayuda war
aber nie da
tun da sagt die luft in berlin ist doch
ein yu-na hat die luft dort nie gerochen
also ergibt in keinerlei hinsicht selben
allerdings will ich an der stelle des
heutigen wieder zu beenden liebe freunde
ich hab ich mal wieder genug ich dachte
das snapshot plus reicht das erst mal
für zwei drei jahre war anscheinend
nicht der fall was haltet ihr von julia
findet ihr sie auch total cool und in
die kommentare lasten daumen hoch unter
dem video abonniert und klickt auf die
glocken weitere videos nicht verpassen
ich
packen denn das kann die nicht